you like making history you for making
history so I got a question for you so
what do you think about the uh uh
possibilities if our current uh
president most popular president of all
time what if he uh ends up deciding to
step down and we experience making
history the first female black president
in America Camala Harris uh how ecstatic
would you be about that monumental
moment if that were to happen I would be
disappointed
really why why would you be disappointed
because she's a
disaster she is she doesn't she she this
would be the worst thing that could
happen to this country why is that
because she's not competent she's just
how did she how did she make it to the
top though how did she make it to be a
VP me some would say she worked very
hard to get to where she's at right now
she worked at being black right and
that's what got her elevated no I just
that that shows you the worst of what
what what race grievance looks like that
he and and any time Nome the governor of
California says I'm going to appoint a
black woman what is that what what do
you mean you're going to appoint a black
woman you're not saying I'm going to
appoint the most competent
person and and to me it shows you how
how degraded the whole issue of race has
become in America it's become it's
become worse than any and it's ever been
I think so you wouldn't be ecstatic
about Kamala no I would not be well Pat
and I both came from California and
people that lived in California will
tell you that when she was attorney
general um how she abused the three
strikes law and the three strikes law um
along with the um determination that if
you had 2 ounces of marijuana or some
level they would say intent to
distribute because of the
quantity and to be tough on crime you
take everybody even minor possessions
you put them in prison and she was very
good at that and she used to speak that
uh very loudly and those of us who are
in California know that that that three
strikes laws may have been well intended
at at one level but what it did was
disproportionately not just in jail 14
days jail at County disproportionately
imprisoned um black men in California
and it perpetuated and by the way when
they went to prison unfortunately what
goes on there is kind of like crime
College
and then they come out they're not
employable so what do they turn to other
criminal Enterprises because it's where
it goes but we all see her as incredibly
disingenuous right about what she what
she oh you you call yourself a
progressive but you also wanted to
appear tough on crime and she'll claim
that well we did this or that these
little programs but she the programs
that she would announce were tokenism
you know we're going to give um gym
membership cards once they get out of uh
prison well they've been lifting weight
for 5 years in prison what need you know
and it was it was tokenism and it was
pandering and it was dancing on both
sides of the political line depending on
who she was speaking to for the purpose
of electability but the real victim in
all this were these citizens who maybe
made a mistake maybe were in possession
but it certainly wasn't distribution and
but they used the three strikes law for
electability and had a devastating
impact on the populace yeah I just think
as a again as a veteran of the Civil
Rights Movement nothing is more
disheartening than this whole notion
that that social justice today has been
defined that for blacks that you must
dumb down standards to moments black
walks into the
door that that I gave examples in our
books about the golden
13 where we pursued Excellence we didn't
ask Jackie Robinson didn't ask well
because blacks were denied access to
baseball that forc strikes and you're
out if you're black Jim Brown and other
other football players didn't say Well
since blacks were denied access to the
NFL that blacks only have to run eight
yards to get a first down can you
imagine you know we we didn't we didn't
ask no we we met we met the standards in
fact I you know but one thing that I
think I'm going to do and I and I've
taken this task on is that if we can
just get rid of white guilt I think the
whole country can can take a side of
relief and get improved that's why I
have become a u a a a self-certified
racial
Exorcist Exorcist racial Exorcist racial
Exorcist So I absolve you from the sins
of slavery and Jim Crow wow I think I'm
thinking about charging maybe $50 for a
certificate so I can get a little race
hustle yeah for I want to get in on the
race hustle too
who knows maybe anheiser Bush gives you
a spot where you're Liv maybe so you
know me it's 30 to 40 million year it's
a nice situation to be in Bob Woodson
can I got a I'm I'm I can't be guilty of
race Bob gave me an Absolution from it
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here